on Tuesdays singer Alicia Keys who
performs as a 2016 Democratic National
Convention of course posted this tweet
it says that's not the right well that's
the right there we go it says our
strength is in our differences our power
is in our diversity we are so beautiful
all of us when we see each other we see
ourselves and it's a picture of her or
another woman in the knee Cobb again
acabas he is the giant covering that
covers your entire face except for your
eyes and then she's wearing what appears
to be a black form-fitting dress with
her legs sticking out of it so you know
the knee Cobb is now a great thing this
is just the sort of empty-headed virtue
signal and you'd expect from a member of
the political far-left who obviously
knows nothing about the way radical
Islam treats women it's the idiocy of
modern feminism in action it would be
one thing to defend the hijab which is
the Islamic head covering that virtually
all religious Muslim women wear it's
another to defend the niqab which is
that face covering into which many
religious Muslim countries force women
here is the fact in the countries in
which women typically wear the niqab
like Saudi Arabia or Afghanistan or
around a woman who exposed her leg the
way the woman does in this photo would
be criminally prosecuted in Sudan in
2015 9 women were flogged for wearing
pants in Indonesia last year a Muslim
woman was flogged for standing in close
proximity to her boyfriend a few months
ago Saudi Arabia arrested a woman for
taking a photograph without her abaya
that's the head covering that kind of
switches around the neck here is what
that brazen hussy was wearing when the
Saudi thought she was immodest yes this
ok the woman received death threats even
before her arrest if her people can't
actually see the picture and listening
to this later she went was a long dress
and a long black coat nothing is
uncovered essentially it is easy to
fetishize foreign cultures but to
glamorize a symbol of oppression for
millions of women across the Muslim
world to pretend that the great threat
to freedom comes from the west which is
willing to tolerate women wearing pretty
much anything rather than a radical
Muslim world that uses the criminal law
to penalize women who violate their
standards of modesty is asinine virtue
signaling that forwards the oppression
of women so much for feminism i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
alrighty so today I actually want to
talk a fair bit about this planned
parenthood moved by the state of
California the state of California is
now charging the undercover filmmakers
who went undercover with Planned
Parenthood and showed that Planned
Parenthood was selling baby body parts
that they were performing abortions in
ways in order to preserve the body parts
of the babies the filmmakers are the
ones in trouble in California find to
kill babies find to sell their body
parts not okay to go undercover to film
people doing this in news reporting but
even that is a mystery of the law will
go through all the law in just a second
plus we will get to the latest from
Trump land and and Bernie Sanders land
and all the rest of the crazy lands that
exist in this bizarre game of thrones
world we now inhabit but first we have
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
helix sleep my wife can sleep through
pretty much anything loud noises or
crying babies or not so subtle advances
from mixes she's definitely alcohol I am
the opposite any sound movement I'm
awake I can't get comfortable sleeping
at least that's how I was before I found
helix sleep so helix sleep sends a
mattress directly to you customized to
your needs you log on to helix sleep
calm / Ben you go through their
questionnaire and then it asks you the
body type and your weight and what kind
of mattress you like and then they send
it to you you take it right out of the
box and inflates for you the only thing
helix sleep cannot stop is my kids
waking me up in the middle of the night
I cannot send them back to helix sweet
but if I don't like the mattress I can
send it back to helix week free of
charge for 109 it's a fantastic product
key would sleep calm / feminity look
sweet calm / been strangely even my wife
says she's sleeping better so that's
pretty spectacular and thanks to our
animation crew here for animating that
often who did that well done often I
like the small Ben and small been female
who are my children that is actually it
people I don't put pictures my kids on
lines because I'm line for obvious
reasons for safety reasons but that's
actually sort of what they eat instead
of funding okay so lots it lots of get
to today so let's begin with this
controversy over Planned Parenthood so
last night it is announced by the state
of California they have charged david
eddings pronounced to layton the Dalit
and maybe and a Sandra merit of the
Center for medical progress on 15 felony
counts over there undercover reporting
Planned Parenthood's from 2015 if you
recall and Ella didn't mayor and Merritt
released video showing that high-ranking
Planned Parenthood members were joking
about selling baby body parts from
market rates and picking through actual
baby body parts in order to demonstrate
which sorts of body parts were available
for the sale of medical research and
talking about the best methods of
abortion for procuring those baby body
parts i want to remind you of what's on
those tapes because this is the stuff
that's not criminal it's the taping
that's supposedly criminal so here is
one of the heads of Planned Parenthood
saying that she wants to buy a lab
rohini with the money that you make from
selling baby body parts atmosphere so
that protects us cool that we're not
going to what we change to and I mean it
also i think it also illustrates things
over the years if I talked about
occupation so let me just call figure
out whatever you getting had my ballpark
in the spine and if you don't we all
there's a lady saying she wants a
Lamborghini from the sale of the baby
body parts and that's not all they
uncovered here's a little bit of the of
these sort of quick and easy guide to
the Planned Parenthood videos I'm Cecile
Richards president of Planned Parenthood
settin up America I want to be really
clear the allegation that Planned
Parenthood profits in any way from
tissue donation is not true
we
generate that income people get their
certain tissues like brain liver thymus
pancreas card long and pretty much
anything on the song is basically a huge
trafficking of fetal tissues the harder
and the more valuable tissue the more
money you get so if you're if you can
somehow procure a brain or heart you're
going to get more money than just like
chorionic villi or umbilical cord if we
alter our process and we are able to
obtain intact feel cadavers it's all
just a matter of line items that would
be a hundred dollars per specimen 50
specimens per day would be five thousand
dollars / 28 that Planned Parenthood was
collecting from fetal tissue extrapolate
about a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars per month that is certainly not
recouping card I 80 cases cases
yesterday and I knew exactly what we
heat it I had looked a little and I said
all right be 17 weeks or having
so I knew which were the cases that were
probably smart like me Toby and I made
my decision support section so if we're
having a hot lesbian in the day long and
that's what I came here that went on
research there are not guidelines and we
can prepare closer and there will never
be done oh just to keep them around to
keep it if they're gonna paint something
like this there are mechanisms by which
the contracts can you review things like
that severity procedures are longer so
than anything that we piggyback onto
that for collection purposes obviously
you know would have to reflect that
additional time costs right
administrative burden we're working with
you know almost like triple digit number
clinics so it's a lot I'm sorry unless
ghoulish stuff I mean they're talking
about the killing of the unborn and then
the sale of the the body parts so this
obviously created a major firestorm
there's talk about the funding Planned
Parenthood hopefully they will still
defund Planned Parenthood that doesn't
have anything to the health care bill it
should just be done on its own there's
no need to provide federal funding for
Planned Parenthood or state funding for
Planned Parenthood which is as I've said
before a baby genocide clinic that's
what / and Parenthood does now what does
California do so important to recognize
the person who initiated the crusade
against David daleiden and Sandra merit
the person who actually initiated that
was Kamala Harris is now the senator
from California she was any attorney
general of the state of California she's
the one who ordered a raid into Layden's
home to try and get a hold of all of the
all of the tapes and now they've charged
15 felony counts so here's what you need
to know legally California is what we
call a two-party consent state that
means that if you and I are on the phone
together and I tape it I can't release
that tape it is actually illegal for me
to do the taping itself that is actually
wiretapping and in the formal sense of
the term I can't do that without your
permission however if you are a you and
I are in a public place and there is no
reasonable expectation of privacy that's
the way the law is written if there's no
reasonable expectation of privacy then
me taping is not a problem so for
disneyland we're talking out loud about
baby tissue then there is no reasonable
expectation of privacy but it actually
goes even further than that so 14 to 15
charges come from the California Penal
Code section 632 a that states in
relevant part quote every person who
intentionally and without the consent of
all parties to a confidential
communication by means of any electronic
amplifying or recording device
eavesdrops shall be punished by a fine
not exceeding 2,500 bucks or
imprisonment in the county jail not
exceeding one year or in the state
prison or by both that fine and
imprisonment now note the language
they're confidential right it's not just
any confidential all parties to a
confidential communication so what does
that mean what is a confidential
communication first off you can see from
these states clearly that some of this
is obviously not confidential they're
doing in the middle of a crowded
restaurant they're talking openly and
loudly it's obviously not meant to be
secretive Planned Parenthood South
Cecile Richards said that people were
saying was publicly in restaurants and
that this wasn't a privacy issue what
they're saying is that some of the other
conversations like there's a point where
they went into some of the medical labs
there's a point where they went into you
can see a private office with some of
the heads of Planned Parenthood they're
saying those were private conversations
so that would be plausible except for
this 2002 case from the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals in 2002 the Ninth
Circuit was asked to rule on a case that
sprang from Arizona so ABC News ABC News
did a segment for primetime live in 1994
and this segment actually ended up
winning a Peabody Award for great
journalism and what they did is they
went into a place called medical
laboratory management consultants and
they were talking about mammograms and
whether they were effective or not
whether they were over prescribed they
went in under cover and here is what the
courts found is a direct quote dev raj
is the person who was the representative
for medical laboratory management
consultants is it Deborah Rodgers
willingness to invite these strangers
into the administrative offices for a
meeting and then on a tour of the
premises indicated that Devaraj should
not have an objectively reasonable
expectation of solitude or seclusion in
the parts of medical lab that he showed
the ABC representatives and then the
court also found no reasonable
expectation of privacy regarding the
conversations between the ABC undercover
reporters and the medical technicians
there's a direct quote from the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals the most
liberal court in the country Devaraj did
not reveal any information about his
personal life or affairs but only
generally discuss medical labs business
operations the pap smear testing
industries about pap smears now
mammogram and Gordon's suppose it plans
to open her own laboratory so the ABC
pretended to be something they weren't
which is exactly what this case was and
then they went and talked to people in a
private setting which is exactly what
this case was and the court found no
problem in fact
the Ninth Circuit said Arizona was not
like California law maybe it would be
different if this were in California but
then they add this quote the expectation
of private of limited privacy in a
communication namely the expectation
that a communication shared with or
possibly overheard by a limited group of
persons will nonetheless remain
relatively private and secluded from the
public at large is reasonable only to
the extent the communication conveys
information private and personal to the
declarant to the deck Laurent meaning
that if none of the Planned Parenthood
members are talking about the stuff they
do in their personal life specifically
there's no problem here that's the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals this case is
directly on point this is what we call
good precedent from the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals so here's the question
where the media today the media that you
know the people who we've been hearing
for months and months months radical
Donald Trump's around okay he's going to
destroy everything tyrannical awful evil
Donald Trump he's going to crack down on
press freedoms and he's going to ensure
that no one is free he's going to throw
people in jail where are they today when
the state of California is taking
undercover journalist which is led to
Layton and Merritt are taking them and
threatening to throw them in jail for at
least 15 years apiece right that's what
they're talking about because the
penalty for each one of these violations
is at least a year there were no more
than a year so 15 years they're talking
about in prison for people taping
conversations that obviously our
undercover journalism and in which there
is no reasonable expectation of privacy
according to the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals whereas the Washington Post
today where is CNN whereas Fox News
imagine for a second imagine for a
second fit back in two thousand twelve
Mitt Romney gets taped by jimmy carter's
grandson and jimmy carter's grandson get
this tape at a private event where mitt
romney is speaking ok and mitt romney is
not speaking even to him he's just
speaking to a private group of people
and this guy tapes romney talking about
the forty-seven percent imagine if
romney sued the guy or more importantly
imagine if the state in which this took
place decided to prosecute jimmy carter
jr or jimmy carter the third and what do
you think media would do you think the
media would stand up for that we think
they would say oh no problem you know
that was a violation of privacy
expectations what do you think would
happen if an undercover journalist let's
say for example that there is an
undercover is there somebody released
without the permission of Donald Trump
tape from latane Access Hollywood bus in
California
right and there was an Access Hollywood
bus and there was tape that Donald Trump
new microphone was on he didn't know the
microphone was on obviously let's say
that somebody took that tape in which
Trump had a pretty reasonable
expectation of privacy and then release
it publicly and the state of California
decided to go after and prosecute the
people over at NBC where wherever this
was taking play the news NBC imagine
that happened do you think that the
press would stand up for the person who
leaked all of this and this is the point
when it comes to principal the left is
completely missing it it just it doesn't
exist if David daleiden had been a
member of Planned Parenthood and they
went into an undercover investigation of
people targeting Planned Parenthood if
they had done an undercover
investigation of live action Lila roses
organization and found some sort of
corruption or something damning and then
they'd released that publicly do you
think the media would be okay with the
prosecution of the people who actually
did that work of course not and this
just demonstrates that when it comes to
principal people are almost always
willing to put their own political
preferences above the importance of
principle and this is just another case
of that this is just another case of
that and it really is quite horrifying
if you are in favor of press freedom
there is no way in hell you should be
standing still for any of this and where
the mainstream where's brian Stelter at
CNN where are those where those wonders
and freedom over at the aclu where are
all the people on the left on this
they're missing in action because they
think it's more important to kill babies
and this guy was a bad guy because he
exposed the fact that killing babies was
a bad thing and that Planned Parenthood
was in the business of killing babies
mean there's video of them actually
picking through baby body parts on a
tray and they don't like that anything
that makes Planned Parenthood look bad
is inherently evil and must be
prosecuted that sort of selective
prosecution on the basis of political
preference is the definition of
political evil okay well I want to talk
more about what's going on you know as
far as the media going nuts on Trump is
actually the big story of the day is the
media losing their mind Hilary is back
out there Hillary's back but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over in stamps com so if you're tired of
waiting in line at the post office
you're tired of using one of those
old-fashioned weighing your postage
machines and you have to go down to that
post office and wait in line for a while
to get the postage you need to go over
to stamps com they are the best in the
business you go to stamps calm and right
now if you go to their
a little microphone in the corner click
on that enter Shapiro but you get a
four-week trial with postage and digital
scale and that means that you can print
the postage out directly onto your
envelope you can print the postage out
onto a piece of paper cut it out tape it
on the tape it on the envelope you can
you can also print it onto a sticker and
they will send you a digital scale so
that you can actually weigh the most you
can do all of it at home you never have
to worry about going the post office
again you don't have to worry about
using one of those old-fashioned scales
you can do all of it just by going to
stamps come by and print you official US
postage for any letter or package using
your own computer or printer saves you
tons of time saves you tons of money we
use it here at the office I've used it
in the past multiple time stamps calm
right now again use my name is Shapiro
go to the microphone make sure you use
this to get that four-week trial with
postage and digital scale go to the
microphone in the corner of stamps calm
click on that enter promo code Shapiro
you get that four-week trial and make
sure again stamps calm enter promo code
Shapiro fantastic service so glad to be
working with them also use that promo
code Shapiro so they know that we sent
you and they continue to advertise with
the program okay so the the media have
lost their minds and the way you can
tell the media have lost their minds is
not just because every day I keep
telling you the media lost their minds
not just because the media are wildly
inconsistent when it comes to things
like the Planned Parenthood tapes but
i'm going to give you two examples of
the media just going nuts and losing
their freaking boards first example
yesterday at the White House press
briefing Sean Spicer is doing press
briefing an April Ryan who's from urban
radio networks I believe American urban
radio networks she starts questioning
Spicer and the most obnoxious possible
way I'm not a Sean Spicer fan I think
that Sean Spicer is far too close to
Melissa McCarthy's impression of Sean
Spicer for comfort but Sean Spicer is is
dealing with with April Ryan's questions
and everybody i saw this clip tweeted
out yesterday and people are going crazy
over and I watched and I was like I
don't understand what the big problem is
here's the clip and you decide for
herself no no I get it but you keep I've
said it from the day that I got here
until whatever there is no question
you've got Russia if the president puts
Russian salad dressing on his salad
tonight somehow that's a Russian
connection but every single person no I
well no that's I appreciate your agenda
here but the reality is uh no no hold on
no
some point report the facts the facts
are that every single person who has
been briefed on this subject has come
away with the same conclusion Republican
Democrat so I'm sorry that that disgusts
you you're shaking your head I
appreciate it but but I'm trying okay
but understand it that at some point the
facts are what they are in every single
person who has been briefed on the
situation with respect to the situation
with Russia Republican Democrat Obama
appointee career have all come to the
same conclusion at some point April
you're going to have to take no for an
answer with respect to whether or not
there was collusion hold on negative I
you know which is that in April hold on
you you it seems like you're hell-bent
on trying to make sure that whatever if
you want to tell about this White House
safe because at the end of the day let
me in okay we're but you're asking me a
question and I'm going to answer which
is the president I'm sorry please stop
shaking your head again okay and that
was the thing that he got always stop
shaking your head again he's a sexist to
he's a racist you never would have said
anything like this okay Melissa McCarthy
again is getting reef Amos off of being
Sean Spicer taking his podium and
bulldozing it into the crowd right the
idea that the trans fights are said this
to April rhyme because April Ryan is
particularly because she's black her
because she's a woman absolutely asinine
absolutely asinine and then April Ryan
is playing this thing up like she was
battered or something here she is on CNN
acting as though this is one of the
worst moments of her life honestly if
Sean Spicer telling you to stop shaking
her head is the worst moment of your
life you lived a pretty fantastic life
here's April lion playing it up it's two
and a half months in there's a
frustration there is something we've
never seen before here at this White
House and sean has to do what he has to
do he is the spokesperson for this White
House but I'm a reporter and I covered
all things presidential to include what
is presidential those investigations on
the hill it pertains to what's happening
here so with everything that's going on
with everything that's going on that was
the question how do you revamp the image
of this White House this administration
has come into a new world Donald Trump
is this this this mobile this real
estate mogul he
a businessman but he is now president a
president ins never had governance and
he's finding his way and he's finding
his way and ways that are hurtful to him
and hopefully not hurtful to the country
okay so she's playing this whole thing
up and everybody on the left is playing
this up this morning Sean Spicer was so
mean to April Ryan up first of all I've
defended april wine before i defended
rape orion there was that situation in
the in the White House press briefing
room during during uh I think Trump
himself was doing the press conference
and at one point he said the April Ryan
can you fix up a meeting between meeting
the Congressional Black Caucus it was
like wait a second that's not her job
that's weird but this one is just absurd
on its face but this wasn't the only
example of the media losing their mind
over something that was almost
meaningless or at least was wildly
overblown would be more accurate but to
hear about that you're gonna have to go
to daily wire calm and become a
subscriber eight dollars a month get to
subscription today lee weyer calm or if
you want to become an annual subscriber
then right now go get an annual
subscription and you get a free signed
copy of the master work that is reasons
to vote democrat a comprehensive guide
from michael j knowles sure the book is
blank but it is as I say completely
thorough you should get it then you
should give it to a democratic friends
who will then become a democratic enemy
you can't stand to see it family dinners
which is great because then you don't
have to invite them anymore more food
for you daily wire calm is where you go
to become an annual subscriber or
regular subscriber or if you just want
to watch her just want to listen to the
show later you can go to iTunes or
SoundCloud or YouTube and go give it a
listen a little bit later if you go to
iTunes please leave us a review we
always appreciate it we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]